Most modern web applications
have elegant URLs.
This helps people remember links,
which then can be easily bookmarked or
shared with others.
As we saw in previous videos,
the route decorator is used to
bind the function to a URL.
But there is more to it,
than just static paths.
We can make certain paths
of the URL dynamic, and
attach multiple rows to a function.
To add variables to a URL, I can specify
a rule, with type: variable_name,
where type can be an integer,
string, or another path.
I will restructure the code for
my menu app as so, and
use the restaurant_id,
to specify which menu I want to see.
Note that it's handy here to leave
this trailing backslash, and
Flask when render the page,
even when it's not there in the URL.
I will save my changes.
And now when I visit
localhost:5000/restaurants/1, I
can see my first restaurant menu there.
If I change the integer
after restaurants,
I can see my other restaurant
menus in the database, as well.